geneticists have to be extremely careful
not to let descriptions of their work
get carried away with enthusiasms about
the level of genetic determinism
involved in different traits there
really is a strong pressure to overstate
and and there was in fact we work in HIV
as well as hepatitis C and there was in
fact an example of this where there was
a genetic finding reported that
suggested that a genetic difference that
is almost completely different between
individuals of African and European
ancestry where you have one form that's
the common form in much of many parts of
Africa and another that's the common
form outside of Africa there was a study
that suggested that this particular
genetic difference and had a gene called
the duffy locus that this particular
genetic difference influenced a
susceptibility to infection with HIV and
the study in fact was not a strong study
it did not have good controls yet
because it suggested that the form that
was common in Africa made people more
vulnerable to infection because it was
suggested that that made people more
vulnerable in fact Bill Clinton picked
up on it and when he visited Africa said
well we now have this genetic
explanation for why there's so much HIV
in Africa and that statement was wrong
from every single perspective the
initial report of that finding other
groups tried to replicate and could not
replicate we do not believe it's true in
the first place and even if it were true
it is certainly not the case that you
could infer from that that the epidemic
of HIV in Africa is in fact due to due
to the underlying genetics as opposed to
other things like behavior so I think
there we had a real example where the
genetics was dramatically overstated by
by a very influential individual and I
don't fault him for that
I actually fault the scientific
community for not being more careful
about what it states as as as real
because what the scientific community
states has an influence on people's
thinking even when it isn't true
and so when this was then corrected as
this as science does correct itself over
time I don't imagine Bill Clinton has
yet said oh by the way what I said
earlier isn't correct and and in fact
the New York Times covered this and I
don't think they've reported anything
saying well now four papers have shown
that you know they can't replicate those
results so I think that's something that
we need to be real real careful of and I
I suppose I would say that that
influential people politicians and
others could probably do a little bit
better job of being careful for example
maybe you pick up the phone to a few
geneticists before you decide to make a
statement like that and say hey is this
convincing as the solid because you
wouldn't in that case have had to ask
too many geneticists before you would
have got some warning signs